Hey good morning well well well look who
decided to drink too much last night
you got to hang out with me your
hangover oh look at you trying to walk
to your desk but you can't because I'm
drowning every single bit of energy you
thought you had when you woke up this
morning idiot hey Quinta whoa whoa we
got a Yeller
we got a Yeller everyone just kidding
I'm giving you a headache that makes you
think everyone around you is Gilbert
Gottfried ha ha you did this to yourself
you know I wasn't supposed to be here
there's a kid with finals today I was
gonna bother but you asked for this so
here I am no it looks like hieroglyphics
to you doesn't it don't you try to take
a walk you know maybe walk this one off
see if that works you feel better that's
cute that's nice that's a sweet mirror
Cole seems too good to be true doesn't
it that's because it is vomit ray bring
to the bathroom ok you're clammy you're
clammy you're really really clammy look
at you you're sweating like Donald Trump
at a taco said I'm having a ball here
people I'm having a good time
ok you suffered enough I guess I'll go
now so I'll catch you next time you
forget you're an adult with
responsibilities don't worry about it
all right we'll just make an impromptu
date out of it all right bye I love you
oh and by the way you have a wedding
next weekend
just let me know if you want me to show
up the day after of course